today is Monday minute is remember why
when times are tough with your business
when people aren't believing in you when
you're not seeing the results that you
want in your business if you're not
seeing any results okay if you're waking
up and you feel like you're talking to
yourself all the time and you're not
getting any momentum with your company
and you feel like you should quit and
give up and you feel like maybe you
should go get a job because nobody's
believing in you if that's happening to
you remember why remember why you
started your business remember why it's
important to why this has to happen
because every entrepreneur goes through
that cycle where they feel like they're
going to give up and then go get a job
and quit and the thing that gets you
through is remembering why make sure you
have a powerful reason believe if you
guys like this video please give it a
thumbs up below leave a comment leave a
question I'm like video response thank
you so much and I'll see you soon